he is one of the stars of 13 reasons why
on Netflix season 3 debuted way back on
August 23rd he's the man who plays Zach
Dempsey and 13 reasons watch but to see
a show how are you sir
I'm doing good man we just watched that
in that clip and yes yeah it's because
we were talking about Ohio State and I'm
football player in the show right and
you know at Ohio State we got the
Buckeyes I heard you're yes I am and so
I do have a couple of questions for you
on an Ohio State playing you play a
football football player on TV I play a
lot of sports but I actually don't play
any of them and realize is that right
yeah no kidding yeah I mean I've played
pickup football a couple times I how are
you throwing I mean can you throw one
very well yeah I think I could throw in
the second season I think I had to play
baseball but I was a catcher so I didn't
have to actually throw the baseball okay
but for football yeah I can throw okay
because you know I'm up a little bit
unless you put me on the spot no I
because we bring that up because the
actor Robbie Amell was seen throwing in
a very odd motion and what I know what
what film this was but he got lit up on
Twitter for it oh no he lit up and I
defended him yeah by saying that there's
cameras all over the place and lights
and you know you have no idea what's
behind the camera very expensive
equipment yeah it's probably like half
half throwing yeah it could just be an
unconventional form you know you you
know there it is right here here's what
Robbie just got totally lit up for that
what I'll say is being a sports player
on TV is usually there's someone right
behind camera that's gonna to catch the
ball for you yeah you don't wanna like
PEG it at their face and they can't send
too far back because you don't know how
your accuracy is Robbie I got your back
that was there was no follow-through it
the the pull back was great but it just
couldn't you couldn't go for it you see
what Ross just did he just gave you 13
reasons why let's reel it
just gave you those reasons why yeah you
know so fight - so let's get into you
went to Ohio State for a year for a year
yeah now where are you from originally C
or Northern Virginia from that tri-state
area okay yeah so how did you get to
Vilnius they they have a good
engineering program okay you know I I
grew up with a single Asian mother who
was very academically driven for me so I
went for chemical engineering okay
decided I hate chemistry and engineering
and so I dropped out
that's a terrible combination if you
hate chemistry and engineering to be a
chemical engineer yeah you know I
thought I liked them until like I
actually do real-world applications of
them like I thought chemistry was just
mixing things together and seeing what
exploded but an engineering was like
fixing that but neither of them was was
for me so Ohio State the apartment the
elastic my bad my bad the trademarked
Ohio State they have a good chemical
engineering program yeah they have like
think top 10 in the US for public
schools huh yeah but I also don't like
the cold and I don't like snow so you
are gonna be successful before the age
of 30
okay so that knit clothes so how did you
get how did you get out here to Los
Angeles to start obviously I decided to
move on a Tuesday and I moved out that
Friday and my mom wasn't happy about it
like literally you're sitting on the
campus in Columbus and you're low you're
back home to DC and I was just trying to
save up some money to live I guess okay
so I could eat right uh and then a
friend of mine connected me with another
friend in LA and he and my friend in LA
was like yeah just come out you should
try it on a Tuesday I talked to them and
Friday I moved out and I took my first
acting class when I turned 21 and here
in Los Angeles
flipped it what was your first gig out
here playing a high school drug dealer
who got in Stanford for a show called
major crimes
there's like a one time I was being
interviewed or at no I'm sorry
interrogated I was selling drugs at my
high school okay and that was my first
role
so did
how'd you break that to your mom hey
guess what I got a first gig I didn't
tell her about that and I playing a
Stanford student yeah exactly
I need you to talk to my money I need
you to sugarcoat everything he's cool
with it now but like you know I for a
while I had to kind of get some credits
before I told my mom okay well look I
mean you you clearly have gotten some
credits yeah you're on a terrific show
right now on 13 reasons why Netflix I've
got Ross Butler here on the Rich Eisen
show why do you think this show works so
well do you think I think it works
because you know it portrays High School
in a really real way and everybody's
been high school everybody knows what
high school is like so I and I think it
portrays it in a light that a lot of
people don't usually talk about it and
about how we all carry a lot of
psychological issues from high school
most of us sure and so I think that's
why it's like the demographics pretty
wide it's like you know we've had people
come up to us anywhere from 15 years old
to 40 years old and it's it's I think
it's just something that has been on
everyone's mind these are topics that's
been on everybody's mind but nobody
talks about
well obviously suicide and then and then
and then depression depression and
potentially causing a massacre in a
school yeah and now obviously season
three right now so these are very
contemporary serious yeah issues and
with this last season kind of elevated a
little bit I don't think there's you
know all these issues going on and
obviously it's it is dramatis eyes for
TV show it's you know in the end it's
entertainment but I think entertainment
is kind of what leads culture it's kind
of how we get to talking about the
things we need to talk about so yeah I
think it just it hit off because it's
been on the tip of everybody's tongue
for for so long did these issues so
we're tackling are any of sure and and
expertly I might add - so anything of
your experience from your real high
school or you know I didn't play
football or I wasn't a jock in high
school by any means um I mean of course
there's like the cliques and there's
like the popular kids and these differ
archetype writers that we see but no I
mean this is but I feel like high school
is so different because you know I'm 29
yes and I haven't been high school for
over a decade so I can see how things
have changed with social media and and
kids are just they're going through a
whole new world now I know I've got I've
got three kids who are gonna soon you
know at least my oldest one is gonna
answer that and I am quite obviously not
looking very much I don't blame you but
you know it's tough I think if they're
growing up a lot faster now then then
maybe when I was nice so if you went
back to you what's your high school that
you you went to Langley high school
Anglia
Wow I said the backyard in the CIA yeah
like if you were driving towards my high
school there's like a driveway that
drives into the CIA that a lot of people
accidentally drive into and every single
time you go down there it's like an hour
process to get out because they're like
why why have you come here what are you
trying to do boy that's the wrong that
is just the worst wrong turn that you
could possibly make yeah it really it's
like there's all these like guard posts
and men with with assault rifles and
it's done don't go to that yeah that's
the reason why I was late for class is
you know if you went back to Langley
high right now
Ross Butler would for like how do you
like me now whether you're with your
some of your classmates no no I was kind
of just so I was a weird kid and I and I
don't say that in a negative tone I say
that more of just like I was always
hopping around these different social
groups and I wasn't really uh I watched
a lot of movies and speaking of I heard
his favorite movies you got mail Oh
fantastic
yeah Chris the word's gotten out I enjoy
mail not my favorite Ryan total babe Tom
Hanks America's homeboy yes no I would
say like my guilty pleasure growing up
yeah that's high school yeah have you
seen 50 first dates with Anna Barrymore
that's it
now I saw that maybe six times in
theaters when that came out and I don't
know why maybe it's the Beach Boys
soundtrack or maybe you just like
anything
than a number in the title you're always
bringing it back to the know I mean look
I think like you like to hang out here
maybe but I mean I know you're here to
prove I'm helping you everything so
although everything with the sequel John
wakes to John week three well no I think
you like the numbers first numbers first
what's 50 first dates 101 dalmatians did
you like that movie as a kid 27 dresses
[Laughter]
well I mean it's just because I was
watching the the interview before this
with Whitney Cummings because I mean
let's be honest coming in it because I
know you're big sports guy I don't watch
a ton of sports okay and and I saw that
we need literally came in with you've
got mail a former chemical engineer
would bring his own robot but I mean you
just came by yourself that's okay I
can't I can't talk about you gotta
that's such like an antiquated thing
that I feel like kids now don't get why
that that was the name of dial into your
computer to get your electronic mail
right yeah there was something called
America Online that when you did connect
via phone yeah it would say you've got
mail you've got man right and these
things called bookstores that's right
where they met in the movie they met in
a bookstore
Bryan's character owned this really
small like boutique family-owned which
dog was really in the real world
eventually achieved shop on the Upper
West Side of Manhattan cheese cheese
cheese shop but that that's fine so
whose favorite movies you've got male it
looks like yeah well no no I'm like you
got the tribute
no Ross Butler I'm just an expert on
everything I was talking about him and
he does not like that's where he got it
from because Whitney coming yeah she
brought she because he go ahead explain
why why you like the film go ahead it's
okay yeah guilty pleasure I think is the
right phrase for but like you know one
weekend when I was a freshman in college
my mom came to visit me surprised me we
went to saw that movie the theater so
I'm very close to my mother and they saw
that you know it kind of makes me think
of her that's nice I didn't see although
did you hear what the first days my mom
did you
he just went though when you we on the
show we think when you go higher
register you don't really you don't
really believe it's alright in its own
right not even from mama's boy theater
its own right okay before I let you go
sir what can you tell fans of this show
that have yet to sit down and stream it
writes all about season four cuz I can
imagine I think your demographic may not
naturally be drawn to the show no it's
not that I have three small children and
anything and that happens after nine
o'clock at night makes me tired mm-hmm
okay well thankfully son that flick so
you don't have to that's true but no
honestly what I said before it really
does help break down the I think the
nervousness of talking about certain
topics because like I said culture leads
conversation I think yes and when you
see something that you feel reflected on
screen that you can't necessarily speak
with your friends or your parents it's
hard to talk about because you don't
have a guide but you know if you can see
people talking about on TV or it being
entertaining on TV it helps start the
conversation and the analogy I use is
watching a rom-com watching these
leading men of how to like talk to girls
on a date or how to just talk with your
friends that that's these are things
that we use in
normal conversation every day right so
when you translate that over into topics
that are harder to talk about I think
it's the same rule I think speaking on
it on TV speaking about in movies helps
to show you how to do it in the right
way interesting and that's how I can get
it for season three is there a season
four already we are shooting season four
now right now right now like we're
shooting up in San Fran and I flew down
just for you rich I feel like you you
really meant that because you were not
higher register yeah and you're also an
upcoming rom-com as a matter of fact to
all the boys PS I still love you which
is coming out next February correct yes
that one so Noah Shenzhen and Lana Lana
Condor I can never pronounce your name
late Lana its Lana Condor okay candor I
love them both but yeah it's that is a
little bit lighter than 13 reasons why
we get to play like people we'll see a
little bit more of my comedic side okay
yeah and I just play kind of like a
jockey high schooler I know it's new
territory for me I've never played a
joke on anything before
well yeah it's it's maybe a Kris you
might like it let's all say you've got a
I'm there for you but it's something is
it something that you can take his mom
to well you don't need to take her to it
you could watch it at home in there you
go on Netflix there you go you know make
your own popcorn and give it a watch
very good fantastic
hey man thanks for coming on the show
really [ __ ] yeah and if you notice that
you know if I didn't appreciate you
coming on the show I'm like hey man this
is great
thanks for coming I like that I would
have gone that yeah but but you sank
down I did Rich Eisen it's funny how you
by the way and I did you also notice cuz
I pick up on all these things he said
that the show 13 reasons why might not
be for what my my demographic is that
what you say is that a way you call me
yeah you have a very youthful low-key I
think it's all my fresh Cod the sports
you talked about it
it's signed with the Cowboys it made me
very happy it's made me younger but
again know my kids that I might have
mentioned at 9 o'clock at night and as
asleep my kids usually go to sleep right
then I don't know if 13 they're not
ready for 13 reasons why you're from
other parts of your over like kc
undercover yes brother I probably have
seen you in many episodes of that yeah
you know it's from your days yeah yeah I
mean wow it's like a it's always a
surprise when I had like a fan come up
and they're like oh we love you so much
from from kc undercover i'm like what
that means they there Oh G fans like
that was one of my first gigs ever
that's yeah you're growing let's put it
down and Instagram 13 reasons why can be
streamed right now on Netflix season 3
season 4 is being made right now thanks
for coming on yes please thank you you
bet that's up that's Ross Butler right
here for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app